okay calm down just me not Tom
celic nice Toby got us all to
participate in movember it's a charity
for prostate cancer you pledge money and
then you grow a mustache for the month
of November so this is how we look now I
hope you like being turned on all the
time damn just keeps on coming huh I
have very fertile hair
glance I am so glad I got all of the
dudes to do
movember we have the dopest time back in
the annex God we can go to lunch pick up
Babes smile if you love men's
prostates actually it's kind of too bad
we're not coming into to work tomorrow
why I bet Michael had some elaborate
theme party planned like scrambled eggs
Saturday like everyone let's get your
boss laid
Saturday
I have an announcement uh to make I am
moving to Costa Rica thought about it
for a long time now and I'm finally
going to do
it
so I'm just going to hop the fence and
Jog home
now
it's a photo of everyone in the office
so you can take it to Costa Rica you not
in it well I was taking the
picture I love it I love
it I would love a picture of the two of
us so also take Su sure do you have a
camera here
uh does anyone have a camera
[Applause]
here no one has a camera here um okay
I'm going to I'll go get
one hey hey I got you one oh wow thank
you yeah just going to grab some chips
you want some no thanks uh we're still
having lunch today right I
guess
how dare
you hey Toby what's this H I just want
to remind everyone about the company
rules involving PDA or public displays
of affection yes uh some people in the
office have complained oh really about
some other people engaging in PDA and
you know just want to remind it's not
appropriate to to do that this is about
me and Jan in my office because I will
have you know that that was consensual
what we did has nothing to do with you
or anyone here I don't think I don't
think anyone heard anything we were very
discreet and and I most people had left
by that point so I don't I don't think
it's any of your business so what I
think you should do is roll up the memo
real tight okay look the memo is not
about you for the record I have never
been involved with anyone at work in any
capacity all right everyone look it all
right the complaint was about Jim and
Pam
so no way what you guys are
together
[Music]
um yep yes we are whoa
wow awesome knew it to the two of you
yes yes Toby was this your fun little
way of congratulating
yes yes oh okay two dim seven Nickels at
one well okay no that doesn't add up it
was one quarter
and but I was just explaining what but
why would it what did you do why what is
it are you going to kiss
me
yes
hey really nice job in there meeting in
there oh thank you I don't know I still
thought I so proud of you hun oh I don't
know
okay just curious so what do you have
against Pete and Aon well Andy wrote me
a really nice recommendation letter for
the adoption agency and I I just sort of
felt I Ed him one he's a pretty cool guy
though and Andy was a Terri terrible
lover to Aaron basically Nord her and
left on a boat I didn't really think
about it like that well not everybody
has what we
have what we have M I just
remembered I kissed that
man
an
[Music]
lady never stop surprising
me
hey what my sunscreen oh great I forgot
mine and I'm wearing a two-piece oh
thanks
Toby hey Toby hey Jack all right man oh
really good how you hey welcome
back oh is that like a new thing or no
I'm sorry no that's cool no it's nothing
we
just all right be back okay all right
all right sorry sorry about that it was
what
nothing
hey hey you know I just realized uh I
don't have a picture of the two of us oh
yeah um yeah could we sure meridi do you
m this one
okay one two
three oh let's do it again Pam your
smile is weird it's digital so just take
as many as you
[Music]
want 1 two
three one two 3
hey hey hey
Toby hey are you
me oh my goodness look
[Music]
at you know look at me I look at
you it's funny right
all right just stay focused on the
pills